here's the thing I'm a longtime Real
Housewives fan Beverly Hills needs you
are you back on it at all you have to
watch I think it is starting in February
will we what are the chances we'll see
you on it I can't like I would love to
like say for sure or not for sure but
it's easier for me just to not get in
trouble and say nothing
well would you go back on the show yeah
Eddie and I we talk about it often and
that's what do you make of all the drama
there's been so much social media
chatter about Lisa Vanderpump and not
getting along with basically the entire
rest of the cast what do you make of all
that
you never know I know what went down
because I'm friends with Denise so I
kind of have an idea of what it is and
you know I think that some of the girls
are like you know 10 years younger
they're doing their own thing they're
not they're jumping off cliffs going to
the Bahamas I I don't picture Lisa ever
do it not you know but at the same time
I think she's such a huge part of the
show can't really imagine it without her
she I don't know I don't think she'll
ever quit everyone's like oh she's gonna
I mean there's obviously you had your
issues with her and there's been so much
talk about you know people have accused
her of manipulating the cast in the show
looking back how real do you think that
manipulation is and is that part of the
problem now and everyone's manipulating
on that show literally from the
producers to the cast the crew like
everyone that is your job to manipulate
and be good at it so I suck at it like
oh I just got manipulated it is just
part of the show interesting what you
say I suck at it but like you don't
sound hesitant to go back on the show
what makes you perhaps excited about the
idea of returning I missed the trips and
the camaraderie and like it's so you
really don't as a grown woman get a
chance to go out with six of your
girlfriends and go and travel the world
and get messed up and
just have a good time you really are
lucky to see I'm lucky to see my friends
every other week for a quick lunch or
dinner because I'm so busy so like
you're basically getting paid to have a
party that's what we're missing brandy
like you brought the fun and a party and
I need that back on my TV again oh well
I'll do what I can for you well then I
guess my question last question but that
would be in terms of what people are
maybe interpreting from social media how
accurate do you think that is knowing
what's really going on there drama wise
gosh I really look at my social media
anymore like I'm really really on it I
mean I have a company that pays me to
post the stories I don't know I really
don't know you don't know until you
watch and even when you watch you don't
know the whole entire story you know the
highlight so you I can never really
judge until we can't judge we're all
kind of it shouldn't alright well Big
Brother do another celebrity season who
would you cast on it I always say that
Andy Cohen should do I know he won't do
it but I think that he is like the
master manipulator because you have to
deal with all of us girls I'm like could
you imagine it's just too much we're all
these different cities and franchises
you'd be really good we're all calling
and texting constantly so I think that
he would be good at it do you have to be
a little bit like well a lot Minnifield
you have to be able to lie pretty good I
know the game yeah I suck at like I
don't like you I really don't like why
would you tell my cuz I don't like him
that's why you're amazing - thank you I
mentioned you and Eddie Todd is that
just you guys working out things like
with the kids in terms of you being on
the show did you say you're Nettie I'm
talking about Eden I could have heard oh
no I'm sorry I thought you said I've
been talking to him about whether or not
I should go back on Andy okay Andy I
misheard you and I'm also just trying to
get you to confirm for me that you're
back on there I never said that
[Music]